if you're scared of being fat you're fat
phobic it's in the definition I'm sorry
to tell you just kidding I'm not sorry
put pause there so it's not in the
definition right the definition of a
phobia is an irrational fear why are you
afraid of fat people why don't you like
it honestly ask yourself this question
but she just said if you're afraid of
fat I don't know anyone who's afraid of
fat people but that wouldn't be the
defin you might be reasonably afraid of
a fat person like a really big fat sumo
wrestler who could maybe just fall down
on top of you and Crush all the air out
of you that would be a rational fear
that you that wouldn't there'd be
nothing phobic or irrational about it